so do you think
bitcoin might reach a million dollars
in value it's uh it's having a current
resurgence
a crazy one in 2021 in the recent months
of uh over 60 000 i guess it is now
do you think it's possible it goes over
a hundred thousand do you think it's
possible goes to a million
you can't rule anything out with bitcoin
so
i mean i'm not you know wanted to put
price targets on it but
one way it could reach a million dollars
is bitcoin's value stays unchanged in
real terms and dollars
crashes all it appreciates yeah instead
um not that i expect hyperinflation but
yeah i mean
look bitcoin is worth about one tenth uh
slightly under one tenth the value of
all the gold in the world
and uh you know gold is worth ten
trillion eleven trillion dollars in the
aggregate
do i think bitcoin can be more
culturally and economically salient than
gold
in two decades time 100
bitcoin was unknown 12 years ago
and today 100 million people worldwide
own bitcoin
so just extrapolate that what is the
level of penetration you think we'll get
500 million a billion you know it
you can easily tune these adoption
curves
however you like i i don't think it's
done
you know monetizing and being adopted
globally
do you think it become it can become
like the base layer for a lot of our
financial operation like
they become the main base layer for all
our transactions
so like even even banks will use bitcoin
essentially and like visa would use
bitcoin as the base there like it would
actually operate
very similarly at the at the surface
layer but at the base there would all be
bitcoin
that's precisely what i expect and banks
and visa are already using bitcoin
so visa has uh
embraced bitcoin in a really big way
actually and it's always funny to the
people saying bitcoin has to
change in a certain way so it can
compete with visa no
visa adopted bitcoin right uh
paypal adopted bitcoin square adopted
bitcoin
obviously they're not tearing out all of
their existing infrastructure but
they're totally engaging with this thing
uh banks
have now begun they got the green light
to provide custody
for bitcoin for their depositors that's
the first step
uh eventually like you know it'll happen
one of two ways
either bitcoin native financial
institutions will become banks
that's already happening there's bitcoin
exchanges that have gotten banking
licenses
or banks themselves will start to engage
with bitcoin as a reserve asset
it'll converge either way that's totally
happening
uh and yes i mean i don't think bitcoin
is going to power every financial
transaction i think it will coexist
alongside sovereign currencies but i
think it's a
great reserve asset it's a very powerful
asset to build a financial system
on top of because it's highly highly
auditable
it's something you can take physical
delivery of very cheaply and those are
great qualities
if you're a depositor in a bank they can
prove to you how much bitcoin they have
they can't really easily prove you know
in the old system how much gold they
held on deposit
and you can easily conduct a run on the
bank you can hold them accountable
because you can withdraw it um because
you know making a bitcoin transaction is
pretty easy at the end of the day
unlike fiat currency it's like kind of
you can't really withdraw all your
dollars from the bank i mean
you sort of can but you're not going to
want to take delivery of
pounds of cash or anything like that so
it's a good modern asset upon which to
build
a financial system basically
you